Ted thank you Uber says you're right
here in Nevada could cost more because
Uber has to pay more in Insurance yes
through a new bill that the writers of
it say keep ride share companies
accountable if there is an accident a
news now reporter Ryan Matthey reports
there's an estimated 30 000 drivers for
apps like uber and Lyft just in Nevada
alone it includes those right outside
the airport here but in a turn of events
Thursday that bill was pulled from its
work session leaving an uncertain road
ahead for drivers and passengers I
average about 20 rides a day James
Cardenas has been an Uber driver in Las
Vegas for two years it's about eight
hours he does it for his two children
and his wife who has another baby on the
way but his income could soon be cut
short if there's no business to conduct
and it's not profitable it doesn't make
sense I I tend not to do things that
don't make sense it's just simply a form
of responsibility they're talking about
SB 125 which would increase the amount
of insurance Rideshare companies like
uber and Lyft are required to pay in
Nevada currently state law requires the
apps to cover fifty thousand dollars
when the driver is logged into the app
without a passenger but Matthew sharp
with Nevada Justice Association which
helped write the bill told the Nevada
Committee of Revenue and economic
development in March that it's not
enough once I accept the ride my private
insurance company no longer covers me
there's an exclusion in your personal in
your own personal auto policy that
you're not covered for for higher
driving it does not exist anywhere else
in the entire country what public
affairs manager for Uber Nevada Harry
Hartfield calls unprecedented every time
you're on a trip with with Uber and Lyft
you have 1.5 million dollars in Auto
liability coverage which is 30 times
what every other car on the road has a
cost he says would be passed on to the
passenger as costs on us increase we do
our best to to absorb as many costs as
we can but we're still a business right
we have to be profitable and make money
now there were not enough votes to move
it forward after a Committee Member
changed their vote against it and it is
unlikely to make any more moves across
the legislature since the deadline to
pass out of committee is this Friday